(audience cheering and applauding)
♪ Desperado ♪
♪ Why don't you come to your senses ♪
♪ You've been out riding fences ♪
♪ For so long now ♪
♪ Oh, you're a hard one ♪
♪ But I know that you've
got your reasons ♪
♪ These things that are pleasing you ♪
♪ Can hurt you somehow ♪
♪ Don't you draw the
queen of diamonds, boy, ♪
♪ She'll beat you if she's able ♪
♪ You know the queen of hearts
is always your best bet ♪
♪ Now it seems to me some fine things ♪
♪ Have been laid upon your table ♪
♪ But you only want the
ones that you can't get ♪
♪ Desperado ♪
♪ Why don't you come to your senses ♪
♪ Come down from your fences ♪
♪ Open the gate ♪
♪ It might be raining, yeah ♪
♪ But there's a rainbow above you ♪
♪ You better let somebody love you ♪
♪ Let somebody love you ♪
♪ Before it's too late ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)